le nombre de patients admis en
réanimation est en baisse en france
une baisse qui se poursuit depuis
quelques jours voilà pour la bonne
nouvelle c'est une mince consolation
alors que le bilan total frôle ainsi les
9000 morts ce n'est donc pas fini
prévient le ministre de la santé ce
n'est pas terminé loin de là nous ne
sommes pas au bout de l'ascension
épidémique
le chemin reste long et rien n'est fini
le confinement fonctionne at il ajouté
en levant en france et on le voit
ailleurs en europe l'italie en est à sa
cinquième semaine de confinement qui est
encore aujourd'hui imposées de façon
stricte et l'on perçoit des signes
encourageants si le nombre de morts avec
636 depuis ziari toujours élevé depuis
quelques jours les nouveaux cas de
coronavirus diminue à milan une nouvelle
directive oblige désormais les gens à
porter un masque pour se re couvrir le
nez et la bouche lorsqu'ils sortent en
public une bonne chose quand les
habitants les encore faut-il en trouver
des masques
je suis pro janot
on ne trouve pas de masques de
protection des plantes ce retraité j'ai
fabriqué le mien les autorités nous
disent qu'ils seront disponibles d'ici
quelques jours
mais c'est ce qu'il répète depuis un
mois c'est la même histoire partout la
course à l'approvisionnement en matériel
de protection est féroce ces boîtes
vides contenait deux millions de masques
de type ffp2 les plus protecteurs ils
ont été volés par un entrepreneur
espagnol selon la police un butin dont
la valeur est estimée à plus de 7
millions et demi de dollars
autre produit tristement demande en
espagne les cercueils entre 8 à 10 fois
plus que d'habitude 17 directrice des
services non tuèrent mais pour une
quatrième journée de suite
le nombre de nouveaux cas est en baisse
une amélioration qui permet de croire
que le pire de la crise sanitaire
il peut être passer un peu plus de
quarante mille patients hospitalisés ont
pu recevoir leur congé des soins
intensifs
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris